vai lá só faltou dizer contra o vôo em 3
2 1
o pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark sejam
muito bem vindos à maia andré leão enfim
eu tenho uma aranha lan ea maranhão
médio agora não interessa onde vamos
fazer um vídeo com 10
não só meu é muito poderoso eu não sei
se vocês lembram mas vocês viram como
evitar um jogador do al 115 eu acho que
já têm usado essa tese para assustar o
ppi e 14 e 73 basicamente funciona assim
o atacante andrezinho e automaticamente
a pessoa cai no chão cai cai
olha ela aí sim mas como não pode fazer
esse teste tem pessoas na época é
perigoso fazer uma coisa diferente eu
vou tentar cozinhar um ovo carne país
muita coisa que eu tenho é que cada um
olha e técnica o novo ponto 200 milhões
de volta em 9 milhões de box é muita
vantagem óbvia pensar em muita vantagem
pode queimar logo queimar pode cozinhar
logo cozinhar pode dar para comer logo
na primeira eu vou comer logo voltei
forma portanto faço vídeo e ainda a moto
não funciona para quem não sabe o que é
um texto não trazia uma arma que é muito
usada nos estados unidos lá pelos
políticos
então as pessoas em casas podem usar lá
e serve para imobilizar potenciais
ladrões ou opções que entrei na nossa
casa sempre tem alguém eu sou cai cai no
chão para que o político da lei pelé com
tudo porque continha um lado só que de
certeza não só agora vai tentar aqui
cozinhar alimentos com nosso país mas
antes já está bem para tentar atingir
uma meta é um só agora a tentar atingir
esta meta e vamos lá cozinhar alimentos
agora que não soava que estamos devemos
atentar que cozinhar o nosso primeiro
alimento também que o jogo - embaixo
tentar pegar o nosso primeiro evento vai
ser a salsicha e porque acreditava que
isso eu acho que talvez a tenha aquela
textura do nosso dedo nem aí
é uma daquelas muito pequenas ainda por
cima tem água né o que quer dizer que só
vai ser ainda mais intenso porque
supostamente a água com dos melhores
óculos de sol e sinceramente nem sei o
que vai acontecer vai queimar vai só
eletrocutar disso vai encher alguma
coisa e não partir daí mais um
ver o que está a funcionar 32 vai só que
em tudo dentro da ficha mil como
absorver um sox oi está muito medo meu
está muito alto não sei se vocês
conseguem ver mas ele é só meu é muito
forte bora lá três vezes não vai ter
como tocar nela porque ela é parte do
choque ele tenha mesmo absurdo olha aí
talvez eu acho que só ficou a escola não
se conseguem ver um stent uma queimadura
olha aí tá que tá que tá mesmo será
queimada ou então só que funciona mesmo
não se conseguem ver mas está um sol
muito tempo a lei
eu sou eu que tenho mais medo é que a
mesma só que eu levo um choque também
porque estou sempre ficar na mesa mas
acho que o tema deve portanto não faz
muito mal não vai votar o próximo
movimento e o próximo movimento e na
filha e por que criamos pouco tempo
também é muito parecido ao ser humano
nem porque é caro ao pecado eu ainda
pensei em tentar cozinhar um bicho
frangote só pizza é muito grosso então
vamos fazer isso com fiambre e vamos
tentar ver o que acontece eu cozinhasse
choque passeio entre os negros a carne é
assim eu não faço ideia mas vamos tentar
agora só 321 e vai daí é só vocês
repararem aqui neste cantinho aqui tem
um cantinho com uma pinta preta e foi um
raio bateu mesmo não seria possível
então o time da toca no ponto específico
enquanto toca
[Música]
muito choque bastida que o fi abrigava
uma ementa do produtor don hahn o dodó
milho e com os baixos lembra mas já fiz
duas experiências com milho aqui no
canal uma foi com a bola quente e outro
foi com laser e é um dos vídeos um milho
pipoca e aí nós vamos testar hoje
pessoal flac ogg pipoca cutait também
não faz ideia mas vamos tentar
eu vou tentar que só colocar um milhão
dentro do prato hipótese comenta invadir
a pipoca não vai virar pó que comentei a
321 vai nem filho nem toca nele há muito
sofre da chamada 321 1 321 vai
vejam só que não penso que ninguém
consegue dormir muito bem muito bem não
só deixou a pequena mesa e eu acho que
de alguma maneira só pessoa entre o
ferro eo encheu o pé e eu venho só que
não perco a faca e medições no corpo
sozinha de lado e vamos apertar o
próximo movimento anticíclico em bateria
nem o próximo elemento é o russo só como
estava o ovo tem gema e clara por dentro
ou seja são líquidos e um líquido com
software livre que você já sabe o que
acontece dentro do ovo foi só colocar
aqui um pretinho e vamos lá só comendo e
também o caso vai conter ou eu vou
explodir não vai facilitar e vai
cozinhar nem tem embaixo e embora
laliberté conselho vamos lá 321 vai
subir um sortudo vai acontecer 321 vai
estranho
lol do ataque mas o muito sério precisa
muito reservado
[Música]
está combinado ainda muito a queimar
etapas e urubus trans
a oim está chegando muita queimada sério
é como se fosse um cheiro bom o público
queimado ao mesmo tempo salvar muito
choque meus só porque por lei
aí eu vou tentar acertar exatamente ali
dentro do buraco bora lá 321 vai dentro
mas eu acho que é possível mas mesmo
assim me tocaram muito só que entretanto
dentro do ovo que faltava para tentar
partir para roma e cozinhar gm deu está
tudo bem agora 321 bairro mesmo não faz
nada qualquer de sua loja a única coisa
que conseguimos até agora foi mesmo a
tal ficha tipo ficou um pouco magoado e
partiu um ovo também mas não cozinhou
mas mesmo assim eu acho que se nós
juntássemos que algumas destas atípicos
juntas com choque elétrico eu estava a
cozinhar o uso só acho que é uma boa
idéia e quiser que incluem vários países
que juntos todos cometem embaixo eu vou
tentar fazer igual só que eu tenho aqui
o trailer não posso usar e ninguém andar
pela casa e vou tentar encontrar pessoal
e vou tentar as estadas curtas e para a
vida real aos 41
ela é mulher anda juízo e não só por
isso de dor espero que vocês tenham
gostado já sabem como tem coisas que não
faço contas eu vou ficar muito mais
coisas e depois comentem em cima mas
podem ver mais vídeos de embalagens
podem se inscrever aqui no canal dar a
quem pessoal ficou em 6 até a próxima